[Música]
uno de los recuerdos más gratos de mi
infancia
ahí por la década de los 70 ese fue el
día en que mi padre llevó a casa una
enciclopedia
esos libros de pasta gruesa que tiene un
montón de fotos y un montón de
información
recordó que ese ciclo piedra de 100
libros 100 volúmenes
y cada volumen se trataba un tema
distinto
yo tenía mis preferidos que era el siglo
21 el futuro las utopías y la conquista
del espacio lo que más me gustaba era
ver sus ilustraciones en donde los
artistas nos proponían un futuro me
gustaba verlos a los autos que volaban
los aviones supersónicos los trenes que
desarrollaban grandes velocidades
inteligencia artificial robots yo
recuerdo que quería que el tiempo pasara
muy rápido para poder estar en ese
futuro yo ya me imaginaba con mi traje
espacial cosechando zanahorias en el
espacio en una cosa así
pues bueno han pasado 40 años y ese
futuro pues nunca llegó como lo plantea
esta enciclopedia
llegó de una forma totalmente distinta
ahora he comprendido que tenemos que
construirse el futuro desde ahora un
futuro de prosperidad un futuro de
abundancia de recursos y precisamente es
lo que te voy a platicar ahora
ese futuro
en donde el conocimiento la técnica la
tecnología adecuada potencialicen el
desarrollo humano para resolver
muchísimos problemas que nos aquejan en
la actualidad
pero por donde comenzamos
después de estudiar diseño industrial
decidir también estudiar un máster en
tecnología tuve la fortuna también de
capacitarme en herramientas y procesos
digitales relacionadas con el diseño
industrial lo cual me permitió
participar en proyectos en el área del
diseño automotriz diseño de aeronáutico
arquitectura entretenimiento entre
muchos otros
estaba viviendo
un éxito profesional
pero algo no andaba del todo bien
no estaba totalmente satisfecha
y sucedía que todas estas herramientas y
capacidades que yo conocía pues carecían
de una aplicación real a mi entorno
inmediato
estaba viendo dos mundos totalmente
distintos que difícilmente podrían
llegar a unirse por un lado
desarrollando proyectos de alta
tecnología y yo viviendo en un lugar en
donde tenemos infinidad de problemas y
necesidades sabrán que es la alcaldía mi
falta es una de las que tienen el mayor
índice de pobreza de la ciudad de mexico
tenemos serios problemas en abasto de
servicios
en abasto de agua potable y un sinnúmero
de problemáticas y en ese aumento me
preguntaba ciertas ciertas cosas por
ejemplo que puedo yo hacer desde lo que
sé desde mi profesión para ayudar al
fondo de estos problemas
después de cierto tiempo y un poco
agobiado con lo que representaba el
trabajo en oficina en el despacho
invertir hasta cuatro horas diarias en
transportar me de casa hasta la ciudad
donde yo trabajaba decidí abandonar un
poco ese es ese camino
y me decidí a emprender un negocio local
con la idea de potencializar la economía
local y también generar empleos
desafortunadamente después de cinco años
pues no me fue muy bien en este aspecto
pero me llevo a un punto de inflexión en
donde yo no tenía los suficientes
recursos
y había llegado un motivante a mi vida
estaba por nacer mi primer hijo
así es que me llevó también a
preguntarme qué puedo yo hacer para
bueno hacerme el responsable de todas
las cuentas que tenemos que pagar de
renta de robert de alimentación de pagar
las cuentas de luz y un largo etcétera
platicando con mi esposa decidió sea
aventurarnos en crear nuestra propia
tecnología así es que nuestro primer
proyecto fue construir una casa
si es así como lo oyen decidimos diseñar
un sistema de bloques y paneles
fabricados con desperdicios plásticos
desperdicios de papel mezclados con
concreto
todo eso lo fuimos montando sobre un
bastidor de acero
cuando el sapo tema no de obras dos
personas trabajando en construir una
casa y lo logramos en solamente cuatro
meses un excelente lugar para vivir ya
han pasado nueve años ya mi hijo ya
tiene ocho años ya tenemos también otro
hijo de un año y medio nos gusta que
también la casa ha sido diseñada para
que también fuera creciendo y ahora
estamos investigando y proponer nuevas
soluciones enfocadas en que sean poco
poco costosas
y también las proporciones son las
grandes acabados
y también fue fuera creciendo toda esta
casa
otro problema que también nos aquejan
muchísimo era el drenaje sabrán que en
la alcaldía mil para muchas personas nos
pueden acceder a este servicio porque
están fuera de la mancha urbana o por
también no pueden costearlo padre del
caso que nosotros teníamos entonces
decidimos desarrollar un sistema de
fosas sépticas que al final procesan
todos los desperdicios y producen abono
orgánico que alimenta un huerto familiar
en donde cultivamos algunas plantas y
algunos vegetales
otro problema que también nos aleja
muchísimo era el agua
en la alcaldía me falta a pesar de que
es una área boscosa y con grandes
recursos hídricos el servicio de red
pluvial tiene serias deficiencias a tal
grado de que solamente por horas una vez
a la semana recibimos este preciado
líquido
decidimos en un principio diseñar un
sistema para captar el agua de la lluvia
y también el agua del rocío matutina
por el momento es agua que logramos
captar solamente lo ocupamos para beber
a través de un sistema de purificación
que la hace totalmente segura para este
fin
estamos en la actualidad en la última
fase de probar un prototipo que extrae
el agua del ambiente el agua que está en
el aire la peculiaridad de este sistema
es que no necesita fuentes de energía
eléctrica o energía externa
y nos fue proveer de agua todo el tiempo
para cubrir totalmente las necesidades
que tenemos de este líquido
también otro problema que aquejaba
muchísimo era la energía
decidimos diseñar un sistema que
aprovecha y que transforma todos los
residuos plásticos domésticos y los
transforma en combustible a través de un
proceso de elevar la temperatura a más
de 270 grados centígrados con un
aprovechamos la radiación solar
el combustible alimenta a una planta
generadora de energía hasta ahora no
hemos dejado de prescindir de la abasto
de energía de la red de suministro
externa pero hemos reducido
drásticamente los costos de energía
eléctrica
ya también ha crecido nuestra familia
y hoy está nos estamos enfocando en algo
muy importante para nosotros es que de
lejos de ver los problemas estamos
enseñando a nuestros hijos a ver las
oportunidades de proponer soluciones
basándonos en tres sencillas reglas que
los dispositivos que diseñamos no
consuman hasta donde sea posible de
energía eléctrica
que sean poco costosos y que podamos
fabricar los con una herramienta manual
esto dado ha dado pauta a que diseñamos
sistemas para conservar alimentos
sistemas paralizar para alimentos
pensando un poco en mi hijo hemos
diseñado juguetes en muebles de cartón y
un largo etcétera
llegó un momento en que decidimos
compartir esto toda esta información a
través de manuales planos diagramas
vídeos constructivos y creamos sitios en
internet creamos y participamos en foros
y creamos grupos de redes sociales para
compartir esto de forma desinteresada
para que la gente pudiera fabricarlos
e incluso pudiera comercializar o
comercializar los habíamos descartado la
posibilidad de que nosotros pudiéramos
fabricar y comercializar estos
dispositivos por lo que eso implica
implicar una gran inversión
y de distribución a altos costos de
distribución y un largo etcétera
creemos en impulsar una nueva economía
local
desafortunadamente contrario de lo que
ustedes se imaginan sucedió que
esta propuesta
recibió un nuevo interés o un número de
interés por esta propuesta en lo que
nosotros preguntamos nos preocupaba esto
porque la gente no se interesa en optar
por esto que estamos haciendo
surge un nuevo problema sucede que un
día regresado del trabajo me encontré
con que las tapas de alcantarilla
estaban desapareciendo
lo que primero hicimos y es hacer un
reporte para que las autoridades se
pusieran esas tapas de alcantarilla y
colocarlo en redes sociales para que nos
ayudaran a recabar información de donde
faltaban estas papas de alcantarilla
sorpresivamente decimos muchísimo apoyo
incluso desde el siguiente paso fue
diseñar y fabricar una tapa con
materiales plásticos estructuras de
fibra de vidrio y también utilizando
concreto la sorpresa fue que recibo
muchísimo apoyo y vamos a tomar algunas
fotos algunas medidas de estas papas
y la gente nos tratado hoy para que las
necesitas que estás haciendo que estamos
haciendo las alcantarillas y donde
podemos vivir donde podemos apoyar esta
iniciativa
comprimimos algo bien importante que es
que los problemas y las soluciones
locales las soluciones que entiende la
gente que conoce la gente esos problemas
de ir que habla con sus familiares con
sus amigos son las soluciones que va
vamos a decidir muchísimo apoyo
incluso vamos a prestar a hacer más
soluciones y entonces se llegó el
momento de proponer nuevas soluciones
claro
estas soluciones iban a ser abarcará más
personas iban a ser atacar problemas
locales y así es que empezamos con
nuestras primeras propuestas hemos hecho
muchísimas propuestas en muchísimos
campos pero es lo que yo te quiero
hablar es solamente tres propuestas las
más innovadoras las más arriesgadas
porque tomamos esa decisión después
solamente mostrarte 33 proyectos porque
queremos retroalimentar nos queremos
escuchar tu opinión de estos proyectos
al principio francamente si alguien me
plantee sus proyectos a mí pensaré que
son una locura
el preproyecto está relacionado con el
acceso a alimentación en la alcaldía me
falta vivimos 138 mil personas de las
cuales 10 miles se encuentran en pobreza
y 7000 en extrema pobreza qué quiere
decir esto que 7000 personas ni siquiera
pueden tener acceso a alimentación
básica
así es que nuestra propuesta es que
sembremos de árboles frutales las
principales avenidas de la alcaldía
yo recuerdo cuando era niño
me gustaba ir con un amiguito que vivía
en el campo y vamos a hacer tareas y una
vez que terminamos de hacer la tarea
salíamos al campo a cosechar frutos yo
regresaba a casa con duraznos ciruelas y
mucho de frutas
además de proponer
fuente de alimentación de forma gratuita
nos interesa más que recuperar ese
aspecto tan humano que todos nosotros
tenemos es de compartir de la ayuda
desinteresada es bien común
a este proyecto le llamamos villa frutal
y nuestro sueño es de que en un futuro
todas las casas afuera de las casas las
banquetas las calles están repletas de
árboles frutales
el siguiente proyecto desde aquí pero te
quiero platicar consiste
y se refiere al acceso a agua
es inminente el colapso de toda la red
hidráulica en la ciudad de mexico
y principalmente también de nuestra
alcaldía cosa que no debería suceder
porque tenemos grandes bosques y grandes
recursos hídricos
la propuesta es que utilicemos las
cuencas
naturales que tenemos en la alcaldía
coloquemos un material plástico de
avanzada tecnología un material textil
para poder capturar el agua pluvial como
una muestra
hemos tomado el cráter del volcán teu
que es el más emblemático de la alcaldía
de esos calurosa roja que podría
albergar y almacenar hasta 300 millones
de litros de agua pluvial que equivale a
más o menos 30.000 pipas de 10.000
litros que podrían abastecer en ningún
problema y podría servir este líquido
para la agricultura y también para las
casas de habitación
el último proyecto también te quiero
platicar se refiere a la energía como
todos sabrán dependemos de
abastecimiento externo
la idea es crear una granja de paneles
fotovoltaicos que serían colocados en la
ladera sur del volcán de un clic
para su construcción se generarían mil
empleos y para su funcionamiento 500
empleos directos
en su versión más modesta y más
conservadora fácilmente está
granjas de paneles fotovoltaicos podría
sin ningún problema abastecer de energía
eléctrica a mil casas
pues bueno todo este esta serie de
soluciones se engloban y es un proyecto
que estoy impulsando al cual le he
llamado alternativa 3
yo estoy haciendo esto desde lo que sé
desde mi profesión que es el diseño
industrial
y también desde lo que me apasiona que
es la tecnología adecuada
pero te invito
seguramente desde tu profesión desde tu
oficio desde tu pasión
puedes visualizar distintos problemas si
eres abogado
si eres ingeniero si eres estudiante si
eres un ama de casa puedes
y contribuir con estas soluciones
recuerda que estamos construyendo el
futuro que mucha gente y sobre todo
muchos niños están en este aumento
visualizando
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]